that's pretty easy because whenever i
describe IQ tests i say that IQ tests
take have a combination of language and
logic and if you do well in language and
logic if you can combine them you'll
have a high IQ and i say that's a
selector for who will be a law professor
and I then mentioned bill clinton
hillary clinton and barack obama who all
three of them were law professors and
clearly they have the IQ kind of
intelligence it's absolutely clear to me
that obama has enormous intrapersonal
intelligence his book dreams of my
father is an amazing book and it's
obviously everybody has lots of
interpersonal intelligence but here's
the here's the big question we don't
know and that is um what is this
existential intelligence like
existential intelligence is one that I
use kind of playfully and that's the
interest in big questions there's no
doubt that he's interested in these
himself but it's not clear to what
extent he's such a pragmatist that he
will lose that sense of mission that
bigger story John Kennedy really
achieved nothing practically as
president but he had enormous power to
excite people to motivate them to think
differently and that's why we still
remember him you know 50 years after the
fact and I'm not sure speaking now in
September of 09 whether the existential
intelligence which Obama clearly has in
his own life is something that he can
mobilize more I mean you know Ronald
Reagan was able to mobilize that I don't
like what he did but there was no
question that he helped people think
about meaning and we thought that Obama
could but it's it's just not clear at
this